all right guys today's a very special
day here in the studio because I'm
unboxing the Rog phone 6 Batman Edition
collector's kit and I'm a big Batman fan
you can tell by the T-shirt here I
collect hot toys I've got a lot of the
figurines I got the two Batmobiles the
89 and the tumbler in Black I've got XM
Studios Batman White Knight bat cycle I
got the Shugo version B I've got a lot
of comic books back home in Vegas and
all different memorabilia I am a huge
Batman fan so when Asus announced this I
was like hell yes I have to unbox this I
have to see what this is about by the
way we're not paid or sponsored with
this video my thoughts and my thoughts
only I will tell you if it's worthy to
get as a Batman collector first and
foremost let's take a look at the box
here real quick if you haven't seen this
already this is the box it's got this
sort of this Batman Insignia band that
goes around it so now we are going to
open this up and I don't want to damage
anything but there's a piece of tape on
the side of it so I'm going to do my
best not to tear I hate it when these
things happen all right so I've got that
open we look on the front of the package
real quick here you can see the Batman
symbol nothing on the back
it's just plain most important is what
is inside the package here
let's undo these lashes
and here we are
all righty okay so it says for those who
dare and text
we've got a couple things going on here
which is very cool of course we've got
this looks like some manuals and some
paperwork
here we have this it's got
Batman on it
that is that oh we've got the ejector
tool with
the bat logo
look at that how awesome is this next
we've got
the Rog brick standard brick on that now
we've got our braided cable it has to be
black because it's Batman and I believe
the cases are inside this package if I'm
not mistaken by the way
then we've got this so this looks like
the bat symbol that lights up and you
can shine onto your wall or ceiling
we're going to try that out in just a
bit once we get everything unpacked and
now to the phone
beautifully wrapped up
all in plastic as you can see brand new
never been opened
should we do the honors yes we shall
let's do the honors
okay
by the way I've never tried the the Rog
phone six I've tried the previous ones
but uh yeah so this is a media sample
kit
you're gonna see that right there
media sample kit okay in terms of the
finish on this it's it's a little bit
not slippery but it's smooth to the
touch but it's got kind of like a nice
velvet feeling touch on the back of this
right that's how I would describe it
really nice very handsome looking phone
you know I know this is some sort of a
gamer's phone but this is more got a
toned down look which I would definitely
Rock if I'm in the office or if I'm out
and about I would definitely take this
out it doesn't scream gamer to me it
screams yeah someone a little bit of a a
different phone than normal but when it
lights up with a Batman logo oh boy I
cannot wait for that so what we're going
to do now is we're gonna go through some
of the accessories before we turn on the
phone how does this go I'm curious about
how this works out looks like you have a
Batman silhouette light let me show that
here you have a Batman silhouette and
then you also have the symbol so you can
kind of go back and forth with the light
which looks pretty cool
all right so we're going to try this out
in just a bit looks like I'm gonna have
to plug this in get this all set up and
I'm going to clear the desk and get all
that going which we will do but first
let's go inside this packaging and let's
see what's inside here everything is DC
Warner Brothers branded on that so
that's very very cool okay this is the
the shawl the protection always good to
have on your phone
I know there's been other phone
manufacturers that have done Batman
editions I think Samsung did a number of
years back okay this one went up to tear
sorry Media Kit Okay cool so it's got
this sort of geometric bat logo on it
right there you can see that then when
you look inside there's Batman inside of
this thing so you've actually got some
really nice
artwork into this there's a lot of
attention to detail which I appreciate I
mean that's one thing Jesus does really
well you got to hand it to Asus they
really do a lot of cool things with
these special editions the Alan Walker
laptop something like this I mean this
is awesome there's nothing else inside
this case by the way so just to keep
that in mind there's nothing underneath
it
boom there it is that's what it looks
like on the phone
very very handsome that's what it looks
like so now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to set this up
then I will come back and we'll go
through all of the features of this
Batman Rog phone 6. and here's a message
from our sponsor this video is brought
to you by Asus introducing the Wolves
first 17-inch OLED foldable screen the
Asus Zenbook 17-fold OLED features six
modes of using the laptop including
laptop mode tablets mode and desktop
mode it offers a laptop experience like
no other with its big and beautiful 17.3
inch foldable OLED Nano Edge touch
screen and transforms into a portable
12.5 Powerhouse laptop when folded great
for productivity enthusiasts alright
guys I gotta show you this real quick
look at that the kickoff screen right
there
that's cool
you notice the first time I used the Rog
phone 6 by the way and I gotta say that
it really feels really good in the hand
it's got a nice size to it
I mean in the camera Department I hear
it's so so but that's okay you know
we're not here for the cameras here's
the thing with this by the way there's
none of that active cooling system
inside of this so if you're looking for
like a Batman Edition with the active
cooling I don't think they make it as
far as I know this is just more for the
phone and the accessories than anything
else so I would say if you want all that
other stuff you're gonna have to use
just the standard accessories that come
with the other Rog phone sixes this is
what it looks like on the home display
look at this thing right here look how
beautiful this is this is absolutely
amazing the wallpaper the icons I'm
already in love and I haven't even used
the damn phone okay I'm gonna add
fingerprint unlock because I hear
there's a bat symbol for the
fingerprints and there is your
fingerprint icon right there the bat
logo I just figured out how to get the
the lighting on the back or at least a
little bit of it going on so I go into X
mode on it and it goes into obviously
you can see it lights up on the back
so you get the bat symbol flashing in
red
and then on the front of it it actually
changes to more of a red look on this
a red background on Batman and the icons
change colors a little bit and of course
when you turn off X mode
there we go that's how you get the
lights on the back of it at least well
I'm sure there's another way too but I
figured this out right now for this
portion at least so I can show you what
it looks like all right I'm gonna try
the camera real quick
not expecting much but you never know
holy skin softening Batman turn that off
this could be a deal breaker if you're
getting skin softening when you don't
even want it
looks like it put on a bunch of makeup
on me holy cow can you guys see this
thing
look at this image
what is going on with this phone let me
try this let me try with portrait mode
okay portrait mode is pretty sharp
that's pretty good not bad that's much
better than the other ones yeah I can't
read the light in this room at all look
at that so I'm sure obviously the
performance is really good but in terms
of the cameras
I'm a little disappointed
in this setup here I'm a little
disappointed now let's look at this
ejector tool now there's a little box
here let's see what this is what's
inside this thing oh okay I get it now I
get it it's a stand for the engine the
ejector tool that's cool gotcha so what
you've got here is a little stand and
this is where you put the ejector tool
on top of it so you can kind of has like
a little bit of a display piece it
doesn't really lock in per se but it's
just there so I mean
I mean it can easily come out you know I
mean this is going to fall out but you
know just put on your desk or whatever
and it's cool
look at that not bad that's that let's
get this uh this light set up here I'm
using some
I think we've got a cable here USBC
cable here let me use this and plug it
in let's see how this performs
oh shoot oh that's legit
that is legit
oh snap
okay it's got that bat symbol on the
wall and it's pretty big oh man you're
going the ceiling with this thing
this may have redeemed the whole package
right here I know this is a bit of a
gimmick I get it but this works really
well
I mean the whole he's got a Batman
silhouette with the bat logo on his
chest and bats around him okay that's
fine but you're all about the bat symbol
right you know you need the bat symbol I
mean you know if you guys can see that
name but that's this is cool
so final thoughts you use an Rog phone
six you know how it performs obviously
it's Prime for gaming not necessarily
for photography as we saw there from
some of the on-screen sample images but
maybe that's there's some sitting in
there I need to adjust I don't know I
just literally have turned it on in this
video but um the accessories are cool
you know you got this little bit of a
this uh Sim ejector tool which is really
nice that's kind of neat put that on
your desk just don't lose it because it
doesn't stick inside that well this
light is awesome but there's no power
switch on it so you just have to unplug
it but I think it's really cool this
would be fun for kids or even in your
room at night and just pop this on this
is really fun I mean it's a nice little
gimmick to that I have to save when it
comes to the phone though I like what
Asus has done with this phone in terms
of the casing and the packaging
everything else uh where the the
fingerprint icon I mean is it worth it
guess if you're a Batman fan I mean it
may be something to consider but you
have to be able to use this phone yeah I
mean look these phones are not cheap
right so I always say find the phone
that's going to serve your needs better
if you're into photography this may not
be the phone for you but if you are in a
gaming or content consumption and you
want a beautiful display and this is has
an awesome display great speakers and
you just want to take in media content
you want a game then I think this may be
a really good option plus you get the
whole Batman kit with you which is quite
cool anyway that's it for the Rog phone
6 Batman Edition let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
any questions you have I'll try to
answer them for you if you like this
video subscribe to the channel and check
out more of our reviews right here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]